all right all right all right what's a
psycho babble here you know we got this
game playing a health a [ __ ] walk-in
dead now this is a hot topic guys I
don't know if you guys have heard on the
television but this series is just
[ __ ] off the [ __ ] hook ok I mean
they got everything they got the girls
they got the zombies they got them
[ __ ] baseball bats with those [ __ ]
screws in them ok so we're gonna play
some of the ship and let's see how this
is going now there's a little behind all
right because there's two seasons and
there's a bonus pack but pocket or
started let's go okay okay um let's
let's do this oh yes a new day episode
one okay let's let's see this loading
that is this this game series adapts the
choices you make the story is tailored
by how you play much like real life
I heard telltale did a good job with
this up oh ok the walking dead ok [ __ ]
episode 1 a new day ok
hargh out here
well much like the u.s. it just seems
like I should always a black guy in the
back of the car you know black lives
matter you know like look at the white
cop keeping his eye on the black guy god
I mean I'm not racist but this is like
my class matter you know like William I
reckon you didn't do it Dan
you know what they say but the reckoning
has really matter
why do you say that now I've driven a
bunch of fellas down to this prison lord
knows how many uses about now I get to I
didn't do it not for me cuz I guys in
your position already said it enough
magic in the nice coffee oh I came about
to get down get down
I load your case a little bit you being
a making boy home what the [ __ ] I'm
making play now you're for making bit
yep came up to Atlanta to be a city cop
in the 70s I always wanted to work a
murder case i guess the senate or i'm
just not yourself mixed up in it would
all due respect a real shame what the
hell let us be regulars at your folks
drugstore right in downtown still there
sure is good i like when they bond when
he's under arrest
I've got nephew up at UGA you teach
there long gun on a six year I need your
wife anything like
I liked Anna wat you won't know how I
see
and I got much choice sure don't
silence regardless could be you just
married the wrong woman whoa whoa whoa
Chimere there I guy but what'd you
[ __ ] say it
to pick up more people or any of that
seem important to you all of it but that
box never shuts up sitting this seat and
pay too much attention and you'll drive
yourself crazy I'm driving this man once
he was the worst one he wouldn't stop
going on about how he didn't do it he
was an older fella big soft eyes behind
a pair of smart folk glasses I like
smart leave my back there is it works in
or vine and snotting all over right well
you hit 40 coming then before long he
starts kicking the back of the seat life
but you see baby on an airplane now tell
him he's got to stop that's government
property and I'll be forced to slap him
otherwise yes then stops and haven't
exhausted all his options he starts
crying out for his mama mama it's all a
big mistake it wasn't me this got kind
of a deck maybe he was innocent Anderson
they caught the [ __ ] red-handed
stabbing his wife cutting her up as the
boys came through the door he sits in my
car screaming bloody murder that it
wasn't him I think he actually believed
it himself it goes to show people up and
go mad when they believe their life is
over I got another good one for you this
one's a little bit less depressing and a
bit more hit little [ __ ] Thompson
as in my first first-ever am making it
[ __ ] hangover ah it's just like one
day is when I get back to the office
my light is so bright
can't look around much like real life
yeah shut but now the zombies are trying
to arrest the black eye yeah yeah I'm
spotting uh Thursday it ah yeah [ __ ]
hangover will get thirsty nice [ __ ]
like no so just [ __ ] abandoned me the
woods some race has ass [ __ ] ok by the
way of the car keep the [ __ ] out what
the hell did he have us come out see
this [ __ ] out oh yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
[ __ ] yo you'll respect your mama oh yeah
and you need to drag myself out that
window mmhmm yeah this ain't your first
already out that window yeah depth
okay men
man I could really [ __ ] up funny
sounds false talk about me oh [ __ ]
chin
all right and I may mr. prevail ER and
this like my first time in a Macy's I
mean they got a lot of things once you
get in there you're [ __ ] like lost
like yeah I kind of sleep [ __ ] you're
eben shotgun oh I don't want to pick up
come on yes I'm like Randy you're gonna
get one like a squat looks intakes it'll
be easier to carry with these cuffs off
yeah and keys around here oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah my main getting them shotgun shells
you know I'm saying back a lot let's get
that shotgun let's blow these [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah well oh [ __ ]
looks empty but i got them shotguns yeah
Carrie with these cuffs off the [ __ ] you
got shells dude who cares was empty [ __ ]
download it now I [ __ ] load it look
at cop I have a shop and feel how do i
use it officer
yeah damn
yeah Dean
she's gonna attack me oh yeah breathable
[ __ ] he's gonna [ __ ] bite me isn't he
oh [ __ ] analyst [ __ ] lost my [ __ ]
just then alright come on don't [ __ ] her
out just on get you afraid on boy yeah
don't let that [ __ ] get away from me
Oh
want to take that [ __ ] take that [ __ ]
load it Vodafone it loaded don't make me
do this yeah come on man just do what
man i gotta feeling that ain't his first
kill you know what I'm saying oh [ __ ] oh
he's like how would I tell ya I killed a
cop that 30 years minimum 30 years he
smells like [ __ ] ill what the hell is
this booty mama dead I'd you hey are you
dead uh it [ __ ] looks like he's dead
you know I am sandy okay what's down
here Jenny can I rock trying to help go
get someone no losing your honor
shooting that's like [ __ ] up in that
spanish chick
Oh
ok
Raulin safe as a bro safe as a bro oh ok
you know then the wall trumpet I play
this game too many times shits on the
wavicle [ __ ] get someone else
hello anybody now this is cruel let's
say let's say anybody anybody up we got
there but no ladder I'm not getting up
there anyway this lady way it is yeah
like I wonder if anybody's home
maybe I should just tick inside the
house through the glass door before
wandering out into the neighborhood Oh
Horace you better see what's inside the
first house you know I'm saying hey
let's say good luck in I wonder if
anybody's home
hello anybody home need a little help
sounds Keys on fish that's how can I
[ __ ] coming in don't shoot okay don't do
puppy thought oh hello I'm not an
intruder what of him
he's still a need more help than I do I
set
you know it's the funks way you know law
coloring books / main priority our wall
likes disgusting gross I hate that Oh
what is this plastic fruit how gimmicky
is this I hate that yes damn oh he just
hate oh jeez all right so many handle
someone like doing the captain there oh
that's the end of the game nope people
up 30 years to die that way sigh beeping
and I about the hell that be penis
that's it I just keep getting tools in
here that [ __ ] in here this place has
been ransacked just about anything
worthwhile as ghost is that hangover oh
yeah just drink my [ __ ] pliant water
okay yeah yeah he's like they won't miss
this I'm a pocket dis [ __ ] it [ __ ]
there this guy doesn't I guess this kind
truly knows if the violence who didn't
give a [ __ ] ourselves people come into
savannah area code like if I wasn't
Alice your mat leave a babysitter I
wasn't really sure about the [ __ ]
apocalypse I want to be in the house
things taken [ __ ] Marsh house that's a
savannah area code that's the type of
note you'd leave a babysitter hey don't
slip a gamma Krakatau Jay there are
three new messages maybe there's
something on there
maybe three new messages message one
left at five forty-three p.m. hey Sandra
this is Diana weren't still in Savannah
and had a little incident with some
crazy guy near the hotel so we had to
get him back to the ER and have it
checked out anyway he's not feeling well
enough to drive back tonight so we're
staying an extra day thanks so much for
looking after Clementine and I promise
we'll be back in time before spring
break message to left at 11 19 p.m. oh
my god finally I don't know if you tried
to reach us all all the calls are
getting dropped and they're not letting
us leave and are telling us anything
about Atlanta please please just leave
the city and take come in time with you
back to marietta I've got to get back to
the hospital please let me know that
you're saying message three left 651 am
I'm a tiny baby if you can hear them
call the police 911
lucky you
I told you I'd ever heard that on the
ant you wish and I would be sad most
famous one thats [ __ ] was spying on
me gladden who know each other barkham
you Maddox quietly I'll be a daddy if
you want me do oh are you okay I'm okay
they tried to get me but I'm hiding
until my parents come home she's the
treehouse ain't she brother she's like
chicka trade how old are you 8 and
you're all alone yes I don't know where
anybody is how old are you I'm uh 37
okay I could be your daddy what's your
name I'm climbin tine this is my house
oh yeah but I'm I'm like ass where are
your parents they took a trip and left
me with Sandra there in Savannah I think
boys until eternity where are you i'm
outside in my tree house they can't get
in that's smart see can you see me i can
see you through the window no screams be
cool Oh climate I'm sorry
how are you good too wow I got pretty
extreme get it
your perspective up
oh I just oh that was sad erotic oh man
hi there he's uh if I was kind of turned
on by that like is that wrong did you
kill it yes yeah it's okay I think she
was a monster I know it's okay in the
hood I think something you've been all
by yourself through this yeah I want my
parents to come home now yeah same here
I think that might be a little while
yeah oh look I don't know what happened
but I'll look after you until there and
this is how much should we do now dang
start starting yeah yeah we need to find
help before it gets dark you know this
seems innocent but like in the truth
this is hell like clicks and gang start
forming like yeah I'll look at the
attacker meanwhile get it cause you the
gang you know you know oh it's like so
too
good thinkin second yeah meal a little
long and you know and I may oh [ __ ]
stairs you're tough
uh-oh and gave up and gay is not have
let no man I never getting home to mama
this right this sucks well it's hot dish
nice got fat Christian be on the right
kill I mean friend though you know
what's the matter should I stay what I
don't want to sleep in the treehouse
tonight but I don't know if I should
leave what if my parents come home I
won't leave you though let's go
somewhere safe that's close okay that's
a good idea hey man holy [ __ ] don't eat
us we're not gonna hurt you yeah I'll
for a second you and the loan we're both
gonna give us the chump what are you
doing trying to get home this
neighborhoods a disaster are you trying
to get out of here because you should be
those things are all over the damn place
I haven't seen anything as gnarly as
this neighborhood since downtown Atlanta
15 miles back I'm Shauna cry she'll
agree that Buckley mrs. Clementine I'm
Chet yeah he likes Jeff you shouldn't be
helped me open like this how about you
help us clear the way and we'll take you
and your daughter out of here sucking on
Jennifer vanities work it should be
safer there I'm not a dad um so
babysitter her parents are out of town
let's get going staying put for too long
as a mistake what do you want to do hi
your monsters come about we gotta go hmm
leave what let's go
his babysitter's go I'd say their
parents are you attend
such is any our church
it might be a trend you know I'm saying
that like my abs like my dad's you know
was saying yeah
hey Shawn I'm gonna run on home my
mama's gonna be in a snit no sweat man
i'll catch you tomorrow night it was
nice to meet you both yo mama it just
goes home sick of dealing nothin
happened what the [ __ ] thank god you're
okay now get everyone together I was
wearing to be bad here too and quiet as
usual the past couple days well brecon
dance well I think some mares gone lame
but that ain't nothin new I wouldn't
have made it back without yet well I'm
glad you took him with you then you
brought helpful guests now guess your
boys a lifesaver glad he could be a help
to somebody so it's just you and your
daughter then oh not his daughter he's
the babysitter honey do you know this
man yes okay then well looks like you
hurt your leg pretty bad there yeah
that's how China so doing so good I can
help you out Shawn run on in and check
on your sister you take a seat up on the
porch and I'll go see what I had thank
you thank you okay raise water let's
have a look yeah yeah that's like let's
just swollen the hell she said oh that's
bad tough guy huh what did you say your
name was Shaquille o its Lee its Lee
nice to meet you Lee I'm Hershel Greene
Hershel oh [ __ ] this is like before
how'd this happen this is like a shell
car accident that's so where you headed
before the car accident
I was getting out of Atlanta the news
says staying yeah well that's a mistake
we hit a guy one of those things you've
been hearing about on the road who you
with the girl Oh nobody is that so yeah
it is you said we [ __ ] is going on here
Oh house is full up with mine we got a
noise place fan yeah 3 sleeping in the
barn he got new your daughter or welcome
to rest there and we're done here I
didn't catch your name darling
clementine can't imagine what you've
been through Clementine um looking after
until we find her parents hey Dad so I'm
thinking first thing tomorrow we got to
reinforce the fence around the farm that
doesn't seem necessary I don't know what
you saw on TV or heard on the radio but
there's some serious [ __ ] hitting the
fan I don't think anyone knows how big
it is yes is that coo coo your son's
right you're gonna want to fortify this
place stuff like that doesn't happen
around here Sean dad I'm serious Lee
come on tell him what you saw out there
man [ __ ] i guess i got cheeks by a
couple of dead people well do what you
think you should we got plenty of chores
as it is lien those folks in the barn
can help out in the morning we got to do
it really I already said okay well I'm
all done here they should start to feel
better tomorrow thanks Julie gets hot or
the slowing doesn't go down you're
probably dealing with an infection what
do we do then we'll probably just have
to shoot you clean it redress it and
you'll be fine okay that'd be preferable
there's blankets and such a barn I will
be seeing you bright and early come
tomorrow which way you think you're
headed towards making I suppose
feel bad cuz I'm I'm always talking to
boy they're talking I get remembers all
good next one
it smells like semen Oh manure manure
like when a horse plops just like that
I missed my mom and dad I bet clue
how far is Savannah pretty far oh okay
Oh UFOs
Jesus the wedging local me like that
sometimes they just take a turn for the
worst you know much like I'll shake
shack skirt hey get up hmm who are you
get away from an itchy well you slept in
a barn little lady lucky you don't have
spiders in your hair but I bet your
daddy scared them all away huh I'm uh
not her dad bigsley I'm Kenny dad no
offense there's a tractor and everything
Nene we better get going or we won't
hear the end of it that's my boy Ken jr.
the column dokdo dick dodging a Kraken
doc yeah nothing bothers him like water
off a duck's back you know that's a
valuable treat lately no kidding but
frankly I think it's because he's dumb
as a bag of hammers it's horrid he makes
up for it with enthusiasm and my word is
you were on your way to making my
family's from there well Macon's on the
way and personally i'd appreciate the
company of a guy who can knock a couple
of heads together if he has to why don't
we get arrested sure will tag along it's
a plan then honey duck this is lee and
what's the girl's name Clementine
Clementine that is a very pretty name
Thanks well we should get to work we've
all seen what those things can do out
there so the faster we get this fence up
the better I want to build a fence yeah
well I need a good Foreman you can sit
on the tractor and yell at me whenever I
take a water break on a tractor
I can keep an eye on your little girl
here on the porch we can visit I like
Emma dance later dance okay sure to
check in with everybody met so far you
have such pretty hair it gets lots of
tangles hey there girls you to actually
look relaxed I think we're doing just
meant I was telling me about first grade
Oh how's that it's easy dad act like
you're interested in first grade so
you're good anyway it's almost like we
didn't see people eating each other for
the past three days it's peaceful Miami
Chicago sec Adele how did you handle get
in through the city can he just drove we
passed so many people that needed help
and we just passed people over some just
just it's okay it's fine you don't have
to say any more I want to go home
tomorrow but even then I can't take away
to the Newsweek just a noise try
something true don't you want to go back
to the moment before you knew about all
of this
anybody in the right line would families
and barbecues beers with good friends
all of those things those are the things
we live for right with those guns point
so uh what are you doing corpses aren't
walking around I'm a veterinarian back
in Fort Lauderdale like Hershel here
except in more with dogs and cats and
not horses what is it that you do be I
used to teach up at the University of
Georgia we need to hope that we can go
back to our jobs back to normal it can't
stay like this
no used to I was let go a little while
back well that's too bad well I hear
people always clamor back to college
after a big disaster he put don't wanna
die ignorant I guess back in a bit okay
Lee check fun time man you having a nice
time we'll catch you a Clementine yeah
good nice and short and sweet I like
that
go faster
get in here nothing happened how are you
doing dark good I'm gonna drive the
tractor I'm the foreman lift with your
back Sean the matter with that kid Haley
dude here that'd be great if you could
cut those to you guys to link that sure
speed things up my man's I don't worry
my dad doesn't know how bad it is no he
doesn't I saw a guy in Atlanta kill a
kid a boy just shot him right in the
face damn hey Dad no that was he didn't
even hesitate you just turned put the
barrel of the gun right between the kids
eyes and pulled the trigger you don't
see things like that it's not like in
the movies they don't fall like your
neck did you have to do it do what kill
have you had dark one yet oh yeah but
I'm out zombie Hannah huh I heard the
soup line yeah you get nikka schumann
maybe if it were far away I'm just glad
we're getting this fence built dad just
wants to keep the family safe and thinks
inviting people in is a bigger threat
than whatever's out there how about
yours how's your family my brother and
parents are in bacon I hope oh man I
hope so terrible Martha maybe it's not
too bad there he's had a tough game
that's probably all I need cut for now
thanks
do you think this thing will keep them
out not yet I'm planning on coming back
through on a fortification pass if you
will we'll lock this place up good yeah
you know how to drive it sure don't I
can give you a hell of a critique of the
u.s. farm bill no I'm good yeah last guy
Amy hey there kidney need any help no I
think I got it do you need any help what
do you mean I mean and taking care of
that little girl you know what you're
doing you got kids your own no just read
it I think I've got it handled okay long
as I keep her safe think I'm doing all
right with those things out there may be
sure that's enough but you got to ask
yourself if you're the type of guy who
can do better than that if her parents
don't show up I'll keep that in mind
he's like oh yeah pants so what's your
family's play get back on down to
Lauderdale and let this mess get sort it
out governmental start handing out shots
and the National Guard will do its thing
on the odd chance things got too bad we
could hop on my boat I guess you've got
a boat I'm a commercial fisherman
catching mackerel dolphin whatever's
biting and paying gotcha wouldn't be
wild about it but the boats not that bad
see you
a second all right I was her
yep looks like he's he's being you know
the Lord in the shepherd you should know
that if you weren't leaving with Kenny
today I wouldn't stand for your lack of
honesty last night oh [ __ ] I'm not sure
I follow I does cut you in that lie last
night about who you were wit net car and
honestly I don't even want to know how'd
you get out of that Lana I got a ride
and then I was in a wreck I walked him
to your boy found me hmm well you're no
worse for wear this farms a nice plot of
land huh had you told me 20 years ago
I'd still be doing man saw what it told
you that you were full of crap never was
a plan having a place like this it was
in the family and guests so was I
family's important that's all that
matters you agree with that was brought
up to yes where's your family now
parents wife girlfriend I ate them my
parents are in making with my brother
well I hope they're all right but now
you've got this little girl to take care
of Clementine is it you just stumbled up
on her it's tangerine and yet in that
client time
yeah I was looking for help at her house
can I give you a piece of advice sure I
don't know who you are what you did
let's say things don't get better back
in the cities or they get worse before
they do you're gonna have to depend on
the honesty of strangers if you're going
to make it and if those same people get
to questioning yours you're gonna be in
trouble but at least you have the common
sense to listen to a man giving you
advice go I'll get my cup
I got you
they
please help me please
shut the [ __ ] out of here
I'm sorry sorry your son is alive you'll
get to be sorry if you you didn't even
try to help
I thought I could help them both look at
him inside round and now
yeah let's go here to hit it makes your
bounds of choice and never come back
like what happened you've got that riser
making if you want
insane
well this is as far as we're going that
it's far enough
look
hey there you friendly trucks run out of
gas
we're close
yep stay here we can't take risks like
this and we can't just let people die
either when I say that door stays shut
no matter what I [ __ ] hot who don't
know who these people are oh it could be
dangerous go drink her bathwater worse
they put a lot of right to us where the
hell is your humanity we have kids with
us I see one little girl for his chin is
massive I can feed off that Chet what is
it hey I have to pee oh I don't hurt
again in a second in a minute clip
they've got kids losing those things
outside don't care oh maybe you should
go join them that um you'll have
something in common god damn it Lily you
have to control these people Carly and
Glenn just ran out there she's the
leader here but it looks like she's
losing control of her people if you were
in my shoes you'd be the holy [ __ ] some
[ __ ] one of them is bitten
he wasn't bitten helly wasn't we have to
end this now over my dead body will dig
one hole no I'm cleaning him up there's
no bite he's bad you [ __ ] people get
it we've seen this happen we let someone
with a bite stayin and we all had the
bitten shut up we gotta throw them out
or smash his head what do we do about
this guy dad it's just a boy it Lily
I'll handle what's your heart dad
because ass you need to calm down Tommy
kick his ass that's what I'm thinking
everyone chill the [ __ ] out nobody is
doing anything shut up well anything
that's going you shut the [ __ ] up they
will find us and they will get in here
and none of this will [ __ ] matter but
right now we're about to be trapped in
here with one of those things what the
hell are you talking about he's bitten
that's how you turn he's not written
please stop this it's a vetting him oh
I'm upsetting him upsetting is getting
eaten alive said I'll fix it you're
gonna would be yeah you and what homo
parade this one that's good little boy
before you say your mommy you can watch
your dad get his nose broken I'm gonna
kill him cat just worried about duck me
yeah there's someone in there it's just
locked keys behind the counter probably
hey I'm not the bad guy here I'm just
looking out for my daughter no you're
just the guy arguing for killing a kid
he's covered in muck she'll find the
bike watch she won't and if she does the
first thing you'll do is sink his teeth
into his mom's face then once she's dead
no probably parts on your little girl
chiltern fast then they'll be three it's
little boy I think we can handle it a
little boy me an uncontrollable maneater
this guy's happen is they were tossing
about now
not this guy Jesus
nice nice hi Clementine I can go you
okay just great thanks you know I real
friends now we're gonna get in
the military I don't know thank God for
whatever it is we almost died because of
this [ __ ] and her itchy trigger finger
that was stupid that was oh he's
transforming he's of Allah
what's wrong with him it's his heart my
pills um nitroglycerin pills yes we're
out we've been trying to get into the
pharmacy since we got here please try to
get in there behind the counter where
the pills are
we'll get in there somehow thank you so
much we need nitroglycerine pills it cuz
please get in there I'll keep an eye on
my dad everyone else should get comfy
and look for anything useful we could be
in here awhile I'm starting to think
this drug store is in the permanent
solution you're right it's ain't exactly
Fort Knox what do you suggest we need as
much gas as possible so we can all get
out of downtown make it fast agreed and
I'll head out and get gas there's a
motel not too far from here I'll towards
the end of Peachtree I'll work my way
towards it and then lose Jack siphoning
what I can yeah okay yeah you finally be
great luck well it's gotta get done plus
I'm quick and I know make it okay keep
ragging that's born and raised if you're
gonna do that here's a walkie-talkie if
you get in a tight spot hopefully you
won't need it cool Clementine it's got
the other one check in with her and get
back here as soon as you can and you
what's your name it's Lily my dad's
Larry keep a good eye on him these boys
will work on getting you your medicine
that's right and you you keep an eye on
that front door you're our lookout it's
Doug you got it and I'm Carly okay Carly
you'll shift in with Doug when he needs
it for now get some rest you're good
shot I'd like to keep it that way you
got it boss now get him those pills
this is crazy too looks like nobody got
a chance to delete anything before this
all went down
hey there hi any word from limb nothing
is he okay yeah I think so you doing a
good job can I get you anything I'm okay
maybe I'm a little hungry I'll see about
that
we'll sit tight okay we gotta get those
pills do I can get to know like you know
like I am
it's not damaged this place didn't get
looted
and it then
both shifts his lives inside
you know what the other people are just
[ __ ] up in the door it's get some
action I'm I crave action like I like
this chance nice denim nice music yeah
like like I what ya can't think about
them in here
ok
no thanks
luckily there's nothing I need in here
oh great Oh is there dead in there
what's that weapon it's my piece this is
my dad's cane heeds ippon here on it
from time to time was he sick no he was
okay I actually saw him whoops
shoplifters with it miss canes protected
this place better than any guard dog
ever could plus he knew how to make it
look cool like you were the head my dad
gave it to me so he danced a smart like
me God would they find out that they're
like that's his daughter and he is her
father be nuts
better get this door clean huh can I
help
of course of course you're the keys here
we go where's lunch of fingers of the
drawers how are you doing yeah it's not
that heavy how about with everything
outside it's not good no it's not but I
think it'll be okay
okay here we go do you have kids no you
don't have a family yeah four wives
their own kids
what are your parents do my mom is a
doctor and my dad is an engineer those
are good jobs what's your job I teach
history in writing I advance Oh social
studies dance yeah like that you didn't
answer my question all right a little
further
why don't you want to talk about your
family do they like hate you not about
them thing i was born in a tube
because they're dead
huh I'm sorry you didn't know I'm just
sorry for being mean but my family's
gone and I just wish things were
different yes I got into some trouble in
and I didn't talk to him for a while
this used to be their store but let's
just keep that between you and me okay
okay because of the trouble yeah that's
right
let's get this done
oh I don't what you are you okay I hurt
my finger is it bleeding a little
there's a [ __ ] horse aid right here
I'll find you a bandage
it's kind of weird in something happen
right now
you
let's have a look at that finger
it hurt let's see if we can do something
about it yeah don't suck on her finger
that's gross let's get this cut covered
oh yes please la da da da da well he's
just like a real doctor
no no you give him the frame imma leave
ya hear what if my parents come home and
I'm not there they'll track us down
don't worry yeah okay we should keep a
lookout I've got my walkie-talkie in
case they try that way stay close to me
into them okay
this music them
get that remote do you know I'm saying
it's the remote to my dad's TV
ah
it's light we need to track down the
keys if we're gonna help Larry
okay wherever the keys make see this
photo let's take the photo there's a
photo over there yeah okay
No
[ __ ] find anything oh [ __ ] us carries
you don't try get me
just a picture of whoever was here I
know who you are
nearly Everett you're a professor at
Athens who killed a state senator who is
sleeping with your wife this is your
parents store folks around town know the
owner's son got himself a life sentence
but I'm a reporter for wabe in Atlanta I
paid attention to that trial maybe
you're a murderer but I don't really
care frankly that's a skill that might
come in handy did you tell anyone out
there who you were or that you were tied
to this place
no I've been sticking the first stage
for a reason are we gonna kiss I'm
really you seem like an okay guy and the
last thing we need is drama out there
you've got this little girl to take care
of it look don't make me wrong on this
hey you like it's been an old players
good because of this last longer than a
few days and you're a detriment to the
group then we'd have a problem thank you
I just keep it to myself yeah thanks Dec
2nd your what kiss don't worry about
thank you sticking in here and ever that
with confrontation
ok let's search his bedding Turks came
in here hoping to spar
looks like one of the most area
wonderful
be a hero maybe protector at least
or anything Oh
that's what I figured
you
he
wanna head back into the drug store with
me okay Lee your what is it you're not
bad right no no no why are you asking me
I'm not that lady said you killed
someone who was that because he was one
of the things trying to eat you
no it wasn't Oh was he bad it was very
bad
I'll stop asking questions ok I guess it
is gonna end that they're
hope you guys enjoyed and stay tuned for
the next one te